[Musique]
Michel David Madeleine glamouret
Christian Dufour bonsoir bonsoir On s'en
va à tarot tous les projecteurs je le
disais un peu plus tôt sont sont braqués
sur l'inflation ce que fera demain la
Banque du Canada on s'attend encore une
autre bien sûr du taux directeur
tire groupé monsieur signe qui demande
des politiques plus agressives pour
aider les Canadiens ce poignet qui
attaque le gouvernement et qui accuse le
gouvernement d'avoir laissé la Banque du
Canada à créer ce contexte
inflationniste je veux entendre d'abord
monsieur signe et Monsieur poignet
on a toujours le droit la capacité de
retirer notre appui donc c'est toujours
là comme une menace qu'on peut utiliser
et ça ça reste toujours là ce qu'on veut
faire c'est de forcer le mouvement de
faire les choses importantes donc on va
continuer de trouver des manières des
façons mettre la pression pour réaliser
les changements qui aident les gens et
ont toujours gardé la capacité de
retirer notre appui
après que le premier ministre a causé le
taux d'inflation le plus élevé depuis 40
ans avec des déficites d'inflationnistes
de 500 milliards de dollars il essaie de
blanc mais le reste du monde mais au
contraire le futur chef des libéraux
marquants et je cite mais à l'heure
actuelle les relations et principalement
une question domestique de majeure
partie de l'inflation et désormais
d'origine domestique donc quel est le
libéraux devrait-il croire leur chef
actuels ou leur futur chef
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien accueilli pression
mondiaux qui cause l'inflation que ce
soit les dérangements dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement que ce soit au
niveau du coup du pétrole et les
pressions sur l'alimentation causées par
l'invasion illégale de l'Ukraine par la
Russie c'est pour ça que nous avons pris
des mesures concrètes pour aider les
Canadiens
alors voilà c'est ça vous donne une
bonne idée du bouillonnement Michel
David je commence avec vous
est-ce que d'abord vous croyez que
l'alliance entre le NPD et les libéraux
vacille ou pas vraiment pas au moment où
on se parle mais je pense qu'il va dans
l'amener qui vient y avoir un moment de
vérité
madame Freeland a été très clair là le
gouvernement n'aidera pas tous ceux qui
vont être victimes de l'inflation au
cours de la prochaine année et il va y
en avoir beaucoup
à quel moment monsieur sing va va
décider que c'est trop peu et que ça
commence à causer un problème même à
l'intérieur de son parti je sais pas où
est la ligne mais l'autre élément et
c'est comme ça depuis le début je pense
de l'Alliance c'est quel serait l'effet
d'une élection sur le NPD au moment où
on se parle est-ce que les gens face à
la perspective de ne voir Pierre
poilière gagner l'élection vont se
rabattre sur et délaisser le NPD c'est
la question que Monsieur signe va devoir
se poser avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'attention le moment où il prendra sa
décision ce qu'on a souvent vu face à
aux parties conservateurs qui pouvaient
prendre le pouvoir les gens du NPD
traversent Madeleine qu'en pensez-vous
je pense que ça va pas du tout en fait
Patrice en ce moment j'ai l'impression
que le NPD a fait un choix en s'alliant
avec le Parti libéral et que il a fait
un choix à long terme en fait quand on
regarde l'entente qui a été conclu entre
les deux parties parce qu'elle a été
rendue publique il y a des marqueurs
dans le temps par exemple le programme
de soins dentaires il est pas mis en
place complètement maintenant il y a une
première étape maintenant il y aura une
preuve chaîne étape l'année prochaine et
ainsi de suite ça c'est pas c'est pas un
hasard si ça a été fait comme ça des
deux côtés finalement on s'est gardé des
marqueurs pour essayer d'avancer et
avancer
à travers le temps pour finalement
garder cette entente là qui tienne
pendant un certain nombre d'années
est-ce que ça va durer jusqu'en 2025 ça
c'est loin d'être certain parce que des
deux côtés il peut y avoir un avantage à
déterminer quel est le bon moment pour
déclencher une élection mais c'est
vraiment pas le moment qui a été choisi
en ce moment là je pense que même
l'année prochaine c'est entente là votre
bien dormir tranquille pendant plusieurs
mois je pense et même si Christian puis
c'est normal qu'il y a des débats
monsieur signe lui la Banque du Canada
est pas d'accord avec son mandat je peux
alien non plus de l'autre côté il y aura
des critiques mais la danse va se
poursuivre Christian en écoutant
monsieur 5 ça me rappelait qu'on était
en face de gouvernement minoritaire je
l'avais oublié pour être franc parce que
l'alliance entre les deux en fait semble
tellement solide mais quand même
monsieur signe de parler de menaces ça
me frappé bon j'ai écouté ce que nous
dit attentivement mais il me semble que
plus le temps pas assez plus ça va être
dans la nature des choses que le NPD
s'éloigne des libéraux parce que bon
c'est classique une espèce de
rapprochement des libéraux puis le NPD
ça pas toujours aider le NPD au fil UV
parce que les libéraux se servent d'eux
et dans la mesure où tant que le
gouvernement Trudeau était hyper
dépensié on sait que ça a été une des
marques de commerce de ce gouvernement
là qui était plus à gauche qui était
plus dépensier que les libéraux
d'habitude bon ça pouvait faire la faire
de Monsieur sing mais là madame priele a
quand même envoyé un message assez clair
on le sait que il y a peut-être pas une
récession mais un ralentissement
économique important qui s'annonce donc
ça peut pas vraiment faire l'affaire de
de Monsieur sing ça critique la Banque
du Canada quand même intéressant de voir
que le gouvernement Trudeau entre
monsieur Poirier qui critique là-bas
Canada parce que à s'occupe pas c'est de
l'inflation puis monsieur signe critique
d'avoir du Canada parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il passait du monde le gouvernement
Trudeau modéré entre les deux donc il me
semble que c'est peut-être encore solide
parce que Madeleine peut convaincu mais
plus le temps va passer
moi il me semble que ça va être solide
par définition
il y a le Parti libéral qui va vouloir
prendre soin de cette entente là comme
si c'était un petit bébé là qu'il faut
que cajoler parce que le Parti libéral
doit avoir du temps devant lui justement
pour essayer de passer cette turbulence
économique là pour qu'elle soit derrière
lui lors d'une prochaine élection donc
en ce moment moi j'ai l'impression que
le Parti libéral va être au petit oignon
avec le NPD pendant un certain temps
vous parlez de turbulences à peu près
tous les en fait tout beaucoup
d'économistes monsieur fait du Gabin sur
ce plateau hier nous disait il y a deux
ans deux grosses années encore de
turbulences où les chaînes
d'approvisionnement ne seront pas
réparés de sorte que les prix il y aura
une pression à la hausse donc des taux
d'intérêt à la hausse alors bref on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge à voir je
change de sujet la GRC
dit aujourd'hui en fait dans un courriel
que les lois la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence Madeleine n'était pas
nécessaire
alors que dogfold lui par ailleurs ne
veut pas se rendre à cette commission
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui se passe
ah oui c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
facile c'est 6 semaines d'audience qui
nous en apprennent beaucoup sur le
fonctionnement interne entre paliers de
gouvernement entre ordre de gouvernement
entre autres si on prend le courriel que
Brenda lockhi la commissaire de la GRC
donc la numéro 1 de la GRC un courriel
qu'elle a envoyé le jour de la
déclaration de l'état d'urgence sur la
scène fédérale elle a dit en fait elle a
dit deux choses si jamais il y avait une
Loi sur les mesures d'urgence voici les
pouvoirs supplémentaires que ça pourrait
nous donner par exemple la perturbation
de réseaux cellulaire l'interdiction
d'avoir des personnes de moins de 18 ans
sur le site donc elle semblait pas
complètement contre cette idée de Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence mais elle
disait par ailleurs et ça c'est tout un
drapeau jaune pour le gouvernement
fédéral par ailleurs on n'a pas épuisé
tous nos outils donc en quelque sorte ça
pouvait laisser sous-entendre que pour
le moment lorsque ça a été déclaré la
loi était peut-être pas encore
nécessaire et c'est tout le débat de
cette commission là la loi elle est
utile son on l'a vu ça a apporté
davantage d'outils dans le coffre à
outils des policiers mais est-ce qu'elle
était nécessaire c'est ce que le
commissaire rouleau va devoir déterminer
on a entendu le maire Watson le maire de
tawa ou l'ancien maire maintenant
d'Ottawa dire qu'elle était nécessaire
le Premier ministre dogford dire qu'elle
était nécessaire maintenant on arrive
avec un son de cloche un peu différent
de la part de la commissaire de la GRC
restons sur la nécessité une seconde
parce que pour Monsieur Trudeau ce
serait quand Christian a un échec
politique c'est la commission arrivait à
la conclusion que c'était pas nécessaire
énorme ce serait une échelle énorme
parce que c'est tout un précédent c'est
un moyen qu'il faut utiliser lorsqu'on a
pas d'autres choix bon on verra mais il
semble-t-il que c'est pas sûr que
c'était nécessaire et je trouve que ce
dossier là c'est un beau gâchis au fond
ça a été très utilisé politiquement
après rappelons qu'au départ il y a
beaucoup de Canadiens qui avaient de la
sympathie pour le mouvement puis que ça
a eu un impact politique ça a été le
premier message qui a été envoyé en fait
par des gens de la base ils ont écouté
là vous êtes trop dans le sanitaire
décrocher un peu mais en même temps ça
s'est mis à déraper des policiers des
services de police on peut sont pas su
comment faire ça donc vivre cette
commission d'enquête là j'ai bien hâte
de voir ce que ça va être le rapport
pour qu'on ait un peu de rigueur
là-dedans puis quand un monsieur fort de
la Premier ministre de l'Ontario c'est
quand même quasiment drôle c'est parce
qu'il s'est sauvé il s'est caché durant
la crise mais il continue à se cacher à
sauver parce qu'il veut pas témoigner
parce que au fond il y a rien à dire
mais c'est très c'est pas besoin d'y
aller en fait le fait qu'ils veulent pas
y aller témoigner ça du tout révélateur
vous êtes Michel sur les deux aspects
allez-y tout à fait monsieur Ford dit
Stan nécessaire et c'est peut-être la
conclusion à laquelle la Commission va
arriver mais si ça si c'était nécessaire
à ce moment-là c'est parce que des
choses qui auraient dû être faites avant
qui l'ont pas été qu'on a laissé la
situation des génériques et Monsieur
Ford à cet égard là et très responsable
comme vous dites il s'est caché pendant
toute cette période là pour des raisons
politiques évidemment ça venait en
élection il y avait certainement une
sympathie pour les camionnettes au sein
de son électorat mais le résultat c'est
que au moment où ça s'est mis à pu être
contrôlable là on peut dire que la loi
est à nécessaire mais pourquoi en étant
venu là c'est à mon sens là la question
mais Madeleine rapidement sur Dark Fox
il a été élu pied allègrement alors
pourquoi pourquoi il se cas pourquoi il
va pas puis pourquoi il parle pas
parce qu'il a été réélu allègrement
[Rires]
est-ce que les gens vont encore s'en
souvenir en ce moment là je ne défends
pas cette position là mais peut-être que
ce qu'il a derrière la tête c'est que
Sylvain témoigner ici le vote témoigner
devant la commission et qui va répéter
que la loi était nécessaire chaque fois
qu'il dit ça il y a une partie de sa
base qui est pas trop trop heureuse de
l'entendre on a entendu entre autres
qu'au sein de la députation fédérale
conservatrice on n'est pas bien content
qu'en dogford se présente en disant
j'étais côte à côte avec Justin Trudeau
dans cette décision-là donc première
chose deuxième chose il va peut-être se
faire quelque chose de très important
c'est ce que vous venez de dire il veut
pas déplaire déjà casser des plus ou
conservateur s'il y allait en plus dire
Trudeau et moi on est on est des amis
oui alors il y a ça et en plus je ne
suis pas une certaine qu'en ce moment
door Ford étant envie de faire une fleur
au gouvernement Trudeau quand il vient
de lire un compte-rendu d'une discussion
entre Justin Trudeau et l'enterrement
Watson et Justin Trudeau dans cette
discussion là disait dogford se défile
de ses responsabilités pour des
questions politiques je suis pas
certaine qu'après ça donc Ford ait envie
d'aller juste un Trudeau
quand même qu'on avait oublié lorsqu'on
fait il y avait peut-être des
considérations politiques électoralistes
mais qui a été réélu allègrement ça
montre que la politique est comme un peu
difficilement compréhensible par moment
parce qu'à l'époque je me souviens là
tout le monde dit sauve on le voit pas
c'était quand même un dossier de
sécurité publique très très important
quelle que soit les raisons et
victorialistes ça rappelle quelque chose
qui était pas glorieux dans son dossier
il y a même qui sera élu trois fois ça
reste dans l'histoire permettez-moi de
faire un dernier heure
Ottawa vient de l'annoncer on rejette du
côté d'Ottawa la fusion entre Rogers et
chat le ministre de l'Industrie donc
François Philippe champagne vient de
l'annoncer officiellement et la ferme
qu'une fusion entre les deux géants du
câble réduiraient la compétition pour
les Canadiens Rogers proposaient
d'acheter son rival chat basé à Calgary
pour 26 milliards de dollars alors il y
aura des réactions puis je vous en
reparlerai
plus tard voilà
je vous ont conclu avec un autre sujet
c'est il y a déjà un tawa qui ont voulu
parler aussi de la monarchie Madeleine
le bloc a déposé une motion on écoute le
chef du blog puis on revient
si on dispose la monarchie il y a plus
de monarque qui prêtait serment l'enjeu
est de
c'est pas important à suivre mon le puis
dans une certaine facilité conviviale
disposons de ça qu'on en parle plus puis
si c'est important voyons voir moi je
pense que ça a de l'importance dans la
mesure où ça établit
qui est le boss et quand on vote on va
dessus dans le vide ou on reconnaît un
monarque étranger
Premier ministre la soumission à la
monarchie c'est pas important pourtant
en homme intelligent le Premier ministre
peut réfléchir à plus d'un sujet en une
journée en politique intelligent et bien
sûr homme de théâtre il peut faire
semblant que non le Bloc québécois à la
journée entière pour parler de
préoccupation de Québécois de canadien
ils ont pour réparer du coup de la vie
pour réparer de l'inflation pour réparer
du travail qu'on peut faire ensemble
dans cette chambre pour livrer pour les
Canadiens mais non le Bloc québécois
surprise surprise veut rouvrir la
Constitution mon Dieu Monsieur le
Président c'est pas ça qui préoccupe les
Québécois ni les Canadiens ces jours-ci
mais ce sont des débats qui nous
rappellent des vieux souvenirs Michel
David tour de table là-dessus il fallait
que le bloc mette son grain de sel si je
peux dire bah écoutez j'imagine qu'ils
ont regardé ce qui s'est passé à Québec
et ils ont dit à Saint sacré bon filon
le PQ a fait un bon bout de chemin avec
ça pourquoi pas nous mais le message
évidemment monsieur monsieur Blanchet
avec sa motion aurait pas ou n'aura pas
une chance sur sur un million de passer
mais le message qui veut envoyer je
pense c'est essentiellement au Québec
moi c'est de dire voyez-vous à quel
point la Constitution est cadenassée
même pour une chose aussi bénigne que ça
il est impossible de s'arranger pour
faire disparaître ça espèce de reliquat
de la conquête alors imaginez-vous les
demandes que le Québec peut faire
oublier ça alors c'est pas tant la
monarchie elle en elle-même qui
préoccupe monsieur Blanchet je pense que
c'est de faire la démonstration que la
Fédération le fédéralisme est
complètement les rosés
Madeleine et je pense qu'il veut se
montrer au diapason avec le Québécois
aussi il y a des sondages qui montrent
que les Québécois sont pas attachés mais
pas du tout à la monarchie et je pense
qu'il veut montrer que certains députés
du Québec qui ne sont pas du Bloc
québécois vont peut-être voter contre la
motion du Bloc québécois donc il veut
probablement embêter aussi les députés
québécois des autres partis quoi que
Patrice c'était assez intéressant de
voir qu'après la période des questions
il y a le Parti libéral qui s'est levé
pour dire
et François Blanchet a dit qu'il n'était
pas sincère lorsqu'il a
prêté serment à la reine donc est-ce
qu'il mérite de siéger à la Chambre des
communes donc là le président de la
Chambre va devoir se pencher là-dessus
donc tout d'un coup il s'est placé dans
une position finalement peut-être un peu
plus délicate qui ne le pensait on va
voir une décision éventuellement du
président de la Chambre à ce sujet-là le
président de la Chambre a dit bon moi je
vais revenir là-dessus là je vais
réfléchir à ça et je vous reviens donc
ça ça s'est passé cet après-midi je suis
pas certaine que le Bloc québécois avait
anticipé ce revenu ce petit
rebondissement là non mais il faudrait
pas que imaginer le tolé s'il faisait
mettre mais il y avait un député du Bloc
qui était parti avec son fauteuil mais
ça c'est une autre histoire Christian
Dufour
bien que vous soyez
émotivement attaché vous comprenez ces
envies de d'en finir avec ses serments
Coudons ce sujet là c'est en train de
remplacer le troisième lien
moi je trouve que autant pour le monde
ça démarche était très intéressante sur
le plan québécois il y avait une
cohérence il y avait une émotion il y
avait une profondeur ça a été très
rentable politiquement pour lui ça a mis
le PQ sur la scène autant Ottawa c'est
complètement artificiel et moi je
comprends pas que le bloc qui est bon on
sent alors qu'il fait parce qu'il faut
qu'il fasse il sait bien qu'il y a pas
sur un million comme anarchie soit aboli
savent la monarchie va être abolir un
grand Bretagne avant de l'être au Canada
il faut être réaliste et moi ça m'a mis
très mal à l'aise un tel opportunisme
politique je suis déjà presque que je
comprends le bloc peut faire peut
présenter une motion formelle une fois
par mois puis là c'est là-dessus qui ont
fait le leurre donc chapeau à Paul
saint-pierre-plan c'est important ça a
touché les Québécois mais là il fait
parce qu'il veut pas voir l'air moins
élevé que par Mondon et moi moi ça me
mettrait mal à la science ça fait Michel
la question sur le débat de la monarchie
allait d'une certaine façon refaire
surface je pense après le décès de la
reine il y a eu quelques jours quelques
semaines qui sont passés et là c'est la
façon dont le Bloc québécois a trouvé
pour animer ce débat là puis
effectivement le Bloc québécois avait
une seule journée d'opposition cet
automne donc il devait choisir de façon
judicieuse c'est le choix qu'il a fait
là après ça bon les électeurs vont
déterminer
de faire de la politique parce que c'est
ça essentiellement ça que Monsieur
Blanchet fait moi je pense que oui et je
pense que on peut parfaitement soulever
une question qui n'est pas
nécessairement la préoccupation
immédiate des gens mais vous savez il y
aura toujours quelque chose de plus
important que ça alors si on prend ce
principe là on en parlera jamais alors
non moi je trouve que ça soit plus
important c'est le multiculturalisme
délirant comme idéologie au Canada c'est
ça la vraie menace du Québec
c'est pas Charles III le problème du
Québec là mais chaque fois que la
mordant mais très bien merci à vous
trois je rappelle Mesdames et Messieurs
que chat Rogers ça a été rejeté par le
fédéral merci à vous trois à très
bientôt pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI